[Music]
[Music]
Oh
gotta go fast
20 minutes ago an energy surge knocked
out power across the entire Pacific
Northwest this needs someone who can
figure out exactly what we're dealing
with you're not suggesting my wife think
you're suggesting we have no choice
what are you in charge here yes I know
my mom mommy charge allow me to clarify
in a switch li ranked hierarchy based on
level of critical importance the
disparity between us is too vast to
quantify agent stone the doctor thinks
your basic listen pal I don't know if
you realize no sorry I major what was
your name benjoe nobody cares meow
basically it looks like I'm gonna have
to save your planet no but thank you for
asking
whatever this creature is our job is to
secure it neutralize it see what makes
it tick
[Music]
[Music]
look at this I took 9 million steps
today
stay in there and be quiet how much
longer I can't breathe in here do you
have your child in that Bank
no I mean yes it's a child but it's not
mine
it's not your child smells like bodies
breaking an old ham sandwich
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]